vous avez entendu ce communiqué de
l'elysée le pas de plus dans la
reconnaissance de ce drame promis
justement par l'elysée at il été fait on
en parle avec notre invité monsieur
ahmed makki fondateur de l'association
mémorielle les oranje
monsieur kaki merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france heures pour que
nous téléspectateurs comprennent que
s'est il passé le 17 octobre
1961 et pourquoi cet événement mérite
d'être connu
alors nous sommes dans le 60e
anniversaire de ce crime d'état et le
mot est important crime d'état pourquoi
crime d'état parce que les manifestants
qui algérien qu'on appelait à l'époque
les ai fait ma les français musulmans
d'algérie
eh bien il était parti se c'était nos
parents il était parti de toute la
banlieue de paris quarante mille
personnes se sont déplacées de toute la
banlieue pour rejoindre paris pourquoi
pour tout simplement manifester contre
le couvre feu discriminatoire et raciste
contrôler seuls supposé algérien et donc
ça c'était intolérable parce que
un couvre-feu qui visait uniquement les
algériens bien c'était intolérable est
véritablement raciste donc nos parents
ce jour là ce sont en dimanche et comme
on dit il y avait des femmes des hommes
il était bon il y avait des enfants et
ils sont partis manifester pacifiquement
à paris et bien
ce jour là et les jours suivants le
préfet maurice papon
avec sa hiérarchie c'est ça qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est à dire le ministre de
l'intérieur roger frey et le premier
ministre michel debré parce que cette
affaire n'est pas seulement une bavure
policière comme on voudrait nous faire
croire ce n'est pas le fait seulement
d'un préfet qu aurait dérapé parce
qu'après fait il est sous l'autorité du
ministre de l'intérieur et du premier
ministre est donc dû gouvernement c'est
dans ce sens que nous disons que c'est
un crime d'état parce que les plus
hautes autorités de l'état ont couvert
ce qu'a fait le préfet maurice papon et
même l'on lui ont donné l'autorisation
de ce crime d'état alors que s'est il
passé précisément nos parents ont
convergé vers paris et sont partis
manifester véritablement peuvent
pacifiquement et dans chaque pont par
exemple le pont de bezons le pont de
neuilly le pont de clichy ils ont été
arrêtés on leur a tiré dessus et on les
a jetés dans la seine eh bien ça a été
pareil dans le boulevard magenta et tous
les boulevards de paris
ça a été des mares de sang partout ça a
été terrible et ses plus de 300
personnes qui ont été assassinés sans
compter les disparus les disparus c'est
à dire d'abord les disparus qu'on a jeté
dans la seine mais aussi les disparus
avec la fameuse phrase de l'époque
administratives les expulsions vers les
douars d'origine en réalité les douars
d'origine ça veut dire les villages
d'origine c'était comme ça qu'il
s'exprimait les autorités à l'époque eh
bien ils ont été livrés à l'armée
française en algérie parce qu'il faut se
rappeler que ce jour là le 17 octobre
1961 l'algérie était un département
français et les manifestants étaient des
effets ma des français musulmans
d'algérie et ça s'est passé à paris et
c'est ce que nous nous disons que c'est
l'histoire de france ce n'est pas
l'histoire des algeria uniquement ça
fait partie de l'histoire messieurs
katie et les français sont amputés d'une
grande partie de l'histoire alors
monsieur jacky je suis désolé on a
vraiment pas beaucoup de temps on a bien
compris ce qui s'était passé le 17
octobre 61 on va parler de ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui l'elysée a promis un
avait promis qu emmanuel macron fait un
pas de plus dans la reconnaissance de ce
drame un pas de plus par rapport à ce
qu'ils avaient fait françois hollande je
crois que c'était en 2012 avait admis
une répression sanglante aujourd'hui
l'elysée je vais citer le communiqué le
président reconnaît les faits les crimes
commis cette nuit là sous l'autorité de
mon espace pont sont inexcusables pour
la république ce pas de plus promis par
l'elysée at il été fait selon vous
alors c'est un demi-pas c'est à dire oui
c'est vrai que c'est la première fois
qu'un président de la république
française se déplacent sur les lieux du
crime et ça nous le saluons
véritablement c'est vrai qu'il faut le
saluer cette affaire on ne peut pas
l'évacuer comme ça c'est très bien
monsieur macron s'est déplacé dans les
lieux du crime mais quand on va dans les
lieux de crime alors il faut nommer les
véritables criminels c'est à dire le
crime d'état et c'est donc ce sens que
je pense que il s'est arrêté au milieu
de la route monsieur macro et il faut
qu'il aille jusqu'au bout pour désigner
pas seulement maurice papon j'ai bien
entendu maurice papon c'est trop facile
de dire que c'est
des comment je veux dire des actions
inexcusable un drame et cela non c'est
plus et plus loin que ça c'est à dire
que maurice papon est sous l'autorité du
gouvernement et donc
la responsabilité du gouvernement de
l'époque est engagé et c'est dans ce
sens que c'est un crime d'état et il
faut que monsieur emmanuel macron va
encore plus loin il a fait un demi pas
il faut qu'il continue sont pas entier
parce qu'on ne peut pas aller dans les
lieux du crime sans citer les criminels
véritable c'est à dire les criminels de
ce crime d'état c'est à dire ceux qui
sont responsables politiquement un
préfet et sous l'autorité
d'un gouvernement il ne fait pas ce
qu'il veut ce n'est pas un type qui
travaille en freelance voyez vous c'est
il ne fait pas ce qu'il veut maurice
papon il l'a fait ce qu'il a fait parce
qu' il ait ils savaient qu'ils étaient
couverts d'ailleurs il a dit des phrases
terribles vous savez il a dit pour un
coup donné nous en rendrons 10 il a dit
allez-y vous êtes couvert c'est ça
ces phrases là qu'il a dit à la police à
l'époque et pourquoi ça a été une
violence inouïe je vais vous le dire
chère madame et bien tout simplement
parce que à cette époque là le premier
ministre
et le ministre de l' de l'intérieur
c'est-à-dire le roger frey et est pas et
pas conduit même il ne supportait pas de
voir des arabes de boue des arabes qui
qui vont manifester dans les rues de
paris c'était intolérable de voir des
algériens qui marchent debout de manière
dean et ce jour là les corses se sont
dépliés les corses sont dépliés car la
colonisation applis et les corps vous
savez c'était une telle répression que
les corps ils ont été pliées et ce jour
là nos parents eh bien ils se sont
dépliés se sont redressés ils ont dit on
n'a plus peur de rien ici c'est la
démocratie c'est paris eh bien on va
manifester malheureusement ils savaient
pas prompt qui s'attendaient à une
hausse au valjoly tels que il y aurait
des mares de sang partout au point que
on pourrait la comparer à la mpt commune
c'est-à-dire depuis la commune il n'y a
pas eu un bain de sang aussi énorme à
paris avec une manifestation pacifique
et je cite ses sources par mcmaster et
jim house les deux grands historiens qui
ont fait un travail magnifique sur ce
sujet monsieur kaki merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir répondu à
nos questions data l'auteur de la pièce
de théâtre 17 octobre 1961 je me
souviens merci beaucoup à vous